Here's a hem or a trim that's
unique and cute as can be.
It's a little fussy, but not too bad and
there are some options for making it your
own.
It's a double bed edge.
I found that a smooth yarn and that
shows stitch definition works best.
Set your machine for full needle rib.
Your pitch will be H.
The tension on both beds
set it to about three.
Set your machine for full needle rib.
Now, even if you normally knit a zigzag,
row at zero, don't do that for this one.
We're going to be manipulating the strands
and we need them to be a little bit loose,
not sloppy, but loose.
You'll want to have a multiple of three
plus two needles and work on the main bed.
The corresponding needles in work on the
ribber, along with the two edge needles on
the ribber.
Knit the zigzag row, and carefully
hang the cast on comb and some weight.
Don't knit a circular row.
We'll transfer stitches as shown.
You'll end up with three
stitches on one needle.
And two empty needles, three stitches
on one needle, and two empty needles.
I started by transferring the stitch
on the second needle on the left of the
needle bed to its neighbor on the right,
and then transferred the next needle back
to that same needle, putting
three stitches on each needle.
This leaves an edge
stitch needle for seaming.
Now work these transfers all the way
across the bed and make sure all of the
needles are in working position.
Knit 4 rows.
Everything should be knitting.
There are no needles and
out of work position.
Next, repeat the transfers over
the same needles in the same order.
Make sure all of the needles are in work
again and continue knitting in full needle
rib.
Can you see the pretty little eyelets
that are formed right along the top edge?
Now this would be a great edge for
a really easy full needle rib scarf.
I don't know about you, but I don't often
knit garments and full needle rib, but we
can still use this pretty scallop.
After you work the two sets of transfers,
transfer the ribber needles up to the main
bed,
but you can continue just
knitting single bed from here.
Okay.
Another thing to notice is that the trim
is quite a bit wider than the stockinette,
so you need to plan ahead a bit, cast on
your edge with fewer stitches than you
need for your garment, and then increase
evenly before switching to stockinette.
Now, having said that, I immediately
thought about the fact that tuck is wider
than stockinette.
The tuck I chose is a
right side facing design.
In other words, the purlside is the right
side of the fabric to create the scallop
edge.
This time I reversed the technique and I
transferred the ribber stitches to form
the scallops.
And then transferred all the
ribber stitches up to the main bed.
This way, the public side of
the scallop trim was facing me.
And as I work the tuck, the public
side of the tuck was also facing me.
The tuck stitch gave me more width and
took care of the flare that I found when I
worked stockinette.
I hope you'll give this edge a try.
There aren't too many steps and
transferring the stitches is well worth
it.